good morning everyone everyone excited
to be back for another day fndc whoa so
to get the energy up I like your
enthusiasm let's give the the conference
a run of applause and some cheering to
make ourselves heard in here all right
perfect all right so we're gonna talk
about c-sharp eight and Beyond my name
is Phillip Ekberg and I'll be taking you
towards the light of f-sharp so
everything that we're gonna learning
here today is gonna make you all great
f-sharp developers all joking aside
c-sharp has over the years taking a lot
of great language features from
different types of paradigms and other
programming languages and we're going to
explore some of the things that are
being added in c-sharp eighth as well as
what's coming in the next versions of
c-sharp as well
it'll be a big focus on the features
adding the the current version of C
sharp which is now c-sharp age eight
which was recently released and of
course we're gonna discover some of the
really amazing things that we might or
might not get over the years too sharp
has had a lot of interesting features
added to the language now when we got
generics in c-sharp - that kind of
changed the way that we build software I
came from a Java world where we didn't
have generics and we still don't so we
kind of missed out on those amazing
features that make it easier for us to
build more reliable applications and
then you know we got things like async
and await in the language wood which
again changed the way that we build
software and even nowadays we we still
learn a lot about async was programming
and the way that we can apply that in
our applications and all these things
change the way that we build our API the
way that we build the software as well
as how we build our packages that people
might download from you get so all these
amazing language features have been
added to the language version prior to
c-sharp aid the in c-sharp seven we've
got things like pattern matching which
will quickly take a look at for those of
you that haven't seen that as well and
one of the really great things about
c-sharp is now that it's open source the
compilers you can go ahead and help out
with introducing language features in
the language if you so like to see if
there's something that you want to see
in the language you can always open a
issue on github and tell them that I
want this feature added to the language
and you're gonna have a long discussion
about why that's not a good idea and
then eventually you'll give up
so this here lists a few of the features
that are coming in c-sharp be next and
we're gonna talk a little bit about
those later on if you're really good
eyes you can see that I have my little
avatar up here so I've actually
contributed to the c-sharp compiler
repository I'll fix the spelling mistake
in this document that's kind of the
extent to my developer capabilities
alright so we're gonna go through a few
of these cool features but there's also
this other repository on github for the
siege of language so the siege of
language has its own repository the
compilers which is what used to be
called Rosling's now these dotnet
compiler platform it's all written in
c-sharp and this language repository
lists the potential features they want
to add to the language right so it's a
totally confusing why this is separate
someone probably thought it was a good
idea and the interesting thing here is
that this is the milestone for c-sharp
aid C sharp F is going to be released
somewhere around 2080 based on the
cadence of the developer features
they're adding it right
although c-sharp aid was released with
dot import we point out which was
supposed to be a part of Visual Studio
2019 although when visuals - to 2019
came out dotted core wasn't really there
and the features for c-sharp ate require
you to be running dotnet course people
know right everyone doesn't know that
but if you're on full framework you
can't really use the c-sharp eight
features so that's a little sad but
everyone should jump on the next version
of.net because that's the best thing
right so let's go through a few of these
c-sharp 8 features enough powerpoint for
a while we're gonna go through some of
these really cool features that are
coming in c-sharp 8 but before we do
that i want to go to go through two of
the major features in c-sharp 7 in case
you haven't seen those it's gonna be
very confusing when we start talking
about c-sharp eight one of the things
that added was an improvement to how we
work with tuples or tuples or whatever
you want to call them so these this
thing here which I'm gonna call double
is probably wrong we have this multiple
values returned out of this method here
so I'm constructing this container of
two fields which is going to have a
named integer of X and I named integer
of Y and this constructs this type it's
not anonymous because what I can do now
is that I can go ahead and call this
method
and this will now allow me to call px
and Peter by but assuming here so that's
useful and what we also can do is that
this isn't limited to two values we can
of course add even more things in here
so you're probably asking yourselves why
do we do this because it's going to help
us when we introduce pattern matching
and we'll get into those features in
c-sharp aid now you can see here that
we're getting some squigglies here
telling us that there's now a problem
here this won't compile because we now
aren't returning the same kind of
container values that we are returning
out of that we were expecting up here so
I'm gonna undo this here otherwise
everything else gonna fail and now
what's happening here is that 100 is now
mapped into my field X and 200 is mapped
into y now I can call this as I showed
you just a moment ago that you can call
this method by just simply calling get
point and this will map the tuple into
this local variable and you get two
fields x and y cannot make sense but
then we can also deconstruct this which
means that we can take the topple and
deconstruct that into something else so
I can say that I want this this tuple
deconstructed into two new local fields
this here is also using the tuple syntax
but now in this local local context here
I can now use x1 and y1 instead right
but it's all about saving characters
over the years the c-sharp language
design team have focused a lot of
efforts into making it easier for us to
write less code so we can improve this a
little bit by saying that instead of
having to specify integer twice you just
infer that so we can say that I have two
local variables they're deconstructed
tuple it'll map X into X 2 and Y into y
2 now what happens if I do this how many
of you think that X is going to be
mapped into x2 leading question it's not
we now have a bug in the application
because now what I'm doing here is that
I'm getting the X and mapping that into
the first parameter here so it's doing
positional matching right so it's taking
the first value and putting that into
the first thing that is deconstructing
so this is helpful for some of us but
it'll be more helpful in c-sharp 8 now
next up they added something in c-sharp
7 called pattern matching if you've ever
experienced other programming languages
like Swift or Catalan or Haskell or F
sharp you've probably seen pattern
matching and how powerful that is to
leverage in our applications so the idea
here is that I have a thing and I want
to match based on the the traits of that
object it could be looking at the
particular type it could be looking at
particular properties and values but in
c-sharp 7 we kind of got a small version
of pattern matching like the first
version that's it's useful but it's not
as good as it could be so we're using
the switch syntax so I'm saying here
based on my shape that I have in my
application this here could be deriving
from the same base type or this could be
an object it could be whatever it
doesn't have to share the same same base
class basically so what I'm doing here
is I'm saying well in the case of the
shape being a triangle what I'm going to
do here is I'm going to cast this object
to a local variable of T which is only
available in this particular context of
that case block so then I can use this
this filter here which we've seen with
exception filters to say when the the
triangles side a and B are not equal
we're gonna match on this case here and
run this block then for all other
triangles that don't match that
particular criteria we're gonna match on
the second one here and if it's a
rectangle we're gonna match on this one
here so that's kind of powerful but it's
pretty much like the the old way that we
build after right so how do we improve
this and make it better for for everyone
well let's jump over to c-sharp aid and
talk a little bit about the recursive
patterns which has been introduced with
the new version I believe that some of
these C sharp 8 features you can still
enable them if you are running on full
frame work but that's unsupported you
can set the language version to c-sharp
8 and it will do its best to compile
that and work with full framework but
when you use things like asynchronous
streams which we're gonna look at later
that probably won't work because the
classes aren't available in dotnet full
framework so now I have this application
here I've translated the same switch
statement that I had into something
called a switch expression
so we have this new thing here that
looks really nice looks more like it's
coming from a functional programming
language so now I can say here based on
my shape here I want to run this switch
block which is now not introducing the
case and break and all of that we're now
leveraging the expressions instead so in
case we've being a triangle again I'm
gonna capture that as this local
variable of T and inside my my
expression here I can leverage that
particular local variable so I can do
t-today here and I can get all the other
ones and I get e intellisense
we all know now that this is a triangle
if we zoom in here that's really nice
and I can't use that outside of of that
block right so I couldn't use it in the
in the next in the next place it
wouldn't know that this exists makes
sense right so in the case of it being a
rectangle
we're gonna catch or we're gonna match
this block here and then we have this
this discord mutation here which is for
all other cases we're gonna match on
this particular block down here now
remember I said earlier that this
doesn't have to be inheriting the same
base class so if you look at the
triangle I could inherit from shape and
that would probably be a good pattern in
my application but in this case here we
have a triangle that doesn't hear it
inherit from anything we have a
rectangle that doesn't inherit from
anything but I can still use this switch
expression to say based on that thing we
can still match on that it's pretty much
like the old if it's you know get type
and it's equal to type off whatever type
you have but this is a nicer syntax now
the difference with this discord or this
default statement here is that if we
compare this to the default keyword in
the switch block this here will in fact
match on nulls as well which I don't
believe it will with whether it would
switch all right so now let's look at
another example a little bit more added
to this switch expression so that kind
of just looked like a translation of
what we had in in c-sharp 7 but with a
little bit of a nicer syntax so in order
for us to leverage the existence of
tuples in the language we can now
introduce more patterns and of course as
you see here we have the triangle we
were matching that on capturing the
local variable we can still apply the
same type of filter that which we did
with the like we do with the exception
filters and we could do that in c-sharp
7 as well but
now with the new patterns we have a few
different things we have a tuple pattern
a positional pattern and a property
pattern so the tuple pattern will all
that was to say if this is a triangle
and then it's going to recursively break
this down and say if I can deconstruct
the tuple linked to something that looks
like this here we're going to match on
this this particular block here so this
means that on our class triangle we now
have a method called deconstruct this
will deconstruct this particular object
into something looking like this here
and I can deconstruct this out to a
tuple and I can use that in my pattern
to match on this particular thing so
what what what that really means is that
I can say for instance with this
reference type here at the end which is
my point for where the triangle is which
is positioned on my screen here I can
say when I have a point or when I don't
have a point I really don't care so we
have this discard notion here as well so
I can say I'm gonna capture whatever is
deconstructed for the first parameter
the second and the third one and I don't
care if you have the fourth or not we
could say that I require this this thing
to match on the particular tuple where
the last one is null right but in this
case I don't care so that's pretty cool
so we can deconstruct the triangle and
match on that so this will use a
recursive pattern to first check it the
type of the triangle and then match on
the particular thing that is
deconstructing - next up we have
something called a positional pattern
which will also leverage to deconstruct
so the same thing with our try with our
rectangle we're deconstructing the width
of the rectangle the height and as well
as the point and in this case here what
I can say is that if the width and the
height are both zero and I don't really
care if you're trying to position this
anywhere on my my screen here because
it's not really a valid rectangle I'm
gonna capture that for this block here
and this is going to return this this
string here of course right so as you
see here as well this method returns a
string and in this switch expression
thing here all of the expressions are
just simply returning strings so this
year of course uses this position based
on how its deconstructing the object so
we could be saying that for all the
rectangles that have the width and
height of 100 we're going to match on
this particular block here if you want
to say that the right
needs to have a width larger than 100
you would have to go up here and use
this this one expression right then we
have something called the property
pattern which allows us to do pretty
much the same thing because you're
probably wondering well in this case
here of the Deconstructor or a
deconstruct I'm just gonna be able to
add that to all the things that I'm not
in charge of if I'm using libraries from
Newgate or whatever it might be
impossible for me to add the deconstruct
and you know developers in the
open-source community might not be
focusing on that right now so what you
can do instead is that you can say well
based on the list being a rectangle
which will be the first thing that it's
matching on then it's going to say if it
has a property called width error and
the value is 100 it's going to match on
this particular pattern right then of
course we can match on any rectangle and
we have this default pattern as well
which uses this discard notion so that's
pretty powerful so of course we can
abuse this which we pretty much can with
any language feature so in some
situations you might be expecting a
boolean here for instance I want you to
based on the boolean being true or false
or null I want to do different things so
if the boolean is true we're gonna have
this item visible if it's false it's
gonna be hidden if it's it's something
else it's gonna be blinking on my screen
here but what's interesting of course is
that it changes to object and it would
still match on that thing so this here
will make sure that it's in fact a
boolean and then that the value is
evaluating to true all right so that's
pretty powerful as well another example
of using the tuples is in this case here
I'm getting an HTTP response message and
based on two of the different properties
on my HTTP response message we have
these two properties the status code and
is successful status code I'm
constructing this tuple here and based
on the values inside this tuple I'm
running this switch expression so I can
say here that if the first value in our
new tuple is not modified as well as a
fruit that the successful status code is
true we're gonna run this thing here
we're gonna load everything from the
cache and then if it's 200 okay and I
don't really care if the successful
status code is set to 2 to true or 4
which is it's always gonna be true right
but it's gonna extract the shape out of
the message and then for all other
status codes where it's a successful
status code everything from you know 201
and upwards it's gonna extract that from
from the shape but if it's a request
timeout and I don't care if the
framework or whatever it's going to tell
me that it's not a successful status
code it's going to recursively run this
method in the real world we would
probably implement some backing off from
the API and so forth and build us
differently but it kind of illustrates
how we can now leverage a tuple and
construct a tuple like we do here and
then write some really nice switch
expression here for matching on that
particular trade of that object and then
of course we have this this final one
which is saying for all of the other
status codes we're going to say that
this is a network error and then of
course we could introduce the the
default or the discard one as well which
will throw another exception right
whoops so that's pretty nice and of
course this this you call this the same
way so you would call any other method
it's role in your application so that's
the switch expressions and the the
recursive patterns that were introduced
in c-sharp eight now let's have a look
at another interesting feature which was
added recently and that's ranges so how
many of you have seen this span of T
here so about half of you seen this
thing this span of T is a way for us to
represent a collection of data without
having to copy the array over or copy
the list over whenever we do try to get
portions of that data when we do
manipulations on the collection of data
itself we don't have to get the memory
overhead of copying it over or or such
right so if I want to grab four to seven
here for instance I can do that in
memory and just point to that particular
set of data and it's super memory
efficient so the way that we do that is
now by we can slice this up to say I
want to grab the fifth element to one
from the last this here is now
introducing this new range syntax which
you can apply in all your different your
your indexes right index yeah
so now we can say here I want to go one
from the end so the Hat syntax is
telling us start off the end and then go
one back so we're gonna get eight here
hopefully and then it's going to give us
the v index so that will be five through
eight I believe so now if we run this
here it should say five six seven and
eight
for some reason when I did this demo
when I built the demo I started off
writing one here but I got totally
confused by myself because I write start
to zero so I always say the wrong number
here but now it works right so we get
the the the five six seven eight
so this here allows us to slice up the
Arang get a new array out of that and we
can run a for each loop of course on
that particular slice and this here
didn't introduce a new array in memory
it's simply pointing to those particular
elements and of course we don't have to
initialize a new local variable we can
do that inline error for each loop as
well so we can say give us the elements
from index 1 through to the index number
four but what's interesting is that this
here introduces something called an
index this here is we can write this as
a what we call an index now which looks
like this so we have our index and we
can say I want you to start from the v
element of the end and I want you to
point to that particular thing so that
would be which number that would be
number five that kind of makes sense
right so how do we get the the last
element well as you see in my comment
here we can say give me zero elements
off the end that would make sense right
if you run this it's gonna tell us that
we're index out of bounds for some
reason if we say I want the the first
index off the end it's gonna give us the
nine totally confusing right so we have
that number nine here I'm printing out a
third thing here but if we go back to
two this range syntax here what happens
if I say give me everything until the
end how many of you believe this is
gonna work and no on it works
so that'll actually give us the all the
numbers from 1 to 9 make sense right
nope it's probably some common somewhere
in one of these language designs
meetings where they talk about this and
someone much smarter than me decided
that this is a really great thing to do
alright so this hair is now pointing to
one off the end which is the last
element so it's not really pointing to
one off the of the end and we can do the
same thing we can create two of these
indices in line here this is gonna end
we can pass these along in here now it's
interesting is if we change this one
here to zero see if that works that
works so it's totally different I guess
if we do one here
that'll give us 6 through 8 but if we do
this let's give us the same thing so
that will give us the correct thing so
whenever we are using the collection
with these indices right so when we were
now saying we're creating an index
that's going to point to one off the end
but if we're trying to use this on the
array like this here we would give a
different element than when we use this
range syntax it's pretty right yeah is
it
right yeah so you're saying that your
it's correct because you're saying that
you start off the N anyone to list all
the elements until that yeah all right
so even though it's correct I still
think it's it's kind of confusing all
right so let's talk about something more
that's confusing let's talk about Na
level reference types so you know over
the years one of the most you know
common problems with in building
software is the nodal reference
exceptions and I believe someone once
calculated on how much money has it cost
the world so you have notes in the
language it's a lot of money right so
now they finally decided that well it
was probably mistake adding Noel's in
the language we shouldn't have nullable
types
so now we can opt in to say that I want
everything in my solution or in my
method or in my class to be appeared as
it's non inaudible which means that we
have to explicitly say that I want to
opt in to have notes in my language
that's pretty cool right so how does
that work well we have this very nice
new project structure and we can now say
that I want nullable enabled which means
that I can now introduce this nullable
types in my programming language and
this is also very confusing but this is
telling us that it's not it's it's
telling us that we're now going to
interpret the nullable types not like we
did before but we're going to allow us
to say that use this new nullable
reference type syntax so let me show you
what that means so on my person here now
I've enabled this new nullable reference
type feature and I now have a knowable
string here so normally what you do is
that you have your string name here and
we we know that this is a reference type
so it's doable right makes sense but now
that I've enabled this feature I have to
opt in to say that this here is now
notable it still compiles but it's going
to give me some warnings you see that
there's these green squiggles everywhere
because this is now telling me that you
have potential no reference exceptions
you should probably go ahead and fix all
of these in some cases the compiler is
correct
you know most of us know better than the
compiler right so if I remove this and
say that well string my string name here
is now not nullable which means that you
have to initialize this the constructor
here is not going to tell us that well
you should probably initialize that but
what happens now is that if we just
apply this in our project or if
especially if you're working with open
source and we have you get packages that
people download if we start just
changing the behavior of our
applications and you know adding more
parameters to the Constructors just to
make this work now of course my person
here is now going to be insuring us that
name will never be null
unless of course you explicitly Adonal
to to the constructor but then you'll
get a warning somewhere else so this
here now changes the contract off the
application and that's not really what
you want so the first thing that you'll
probably do let's undo this here to get
rid of that warning inside this class
you will probably say that well I I'll
have this as a knowable and I'll see
wherever else in my application this
might be a problem so we can immediately
see here that in this method called
insert or update we are now getting a
squiggly here telling us that well you
you have a problem here and this could
potentially be referencing a null null
name right so we're trying to get the
the length out of our name here and
that's going to be null so I can say
well don't get the line if it's null
then so we can use the same thing that
we did earlier right but then we're
going to start up having question marks
everywhere in the code and that's you
know we're making up for the characters
that we saved we can also do another
thing we can promise the compiler that
name effect here isn't null so they
unofficially this is called the damage
operator I think that's a great name I
don't know what the that's unofficial
names I don't know what the official
name is so now we are let's fix this by
saying question mark here to say that if
this isn't if this is no don't care why
to get length and of course person here
is a reference type and this here since
I've enabled the nullable reference
types this is now a non notable person
or we were trying to promise that this
is never going to be null but I can say
that well I want this to be able to be
null and now we're gonna get another
squiggly down here telling us that
person here is potential
we know so let's not get the name and
then let's not get the length is if any
of those are not starts to get pretty
nasty let's undo that but you know what
happens if we now try to to call this
insert or update method and an adding
null here now it's probably gonna tell
us that well you have the same problem
that hit earlier you you can't really
send null in here because this here
expects a non inaudible type but you
know I know better than the compiler
said this is not going to be a null
object so the Ordnung goes away this
kind of illustrates one of the
interesting problems with this now of
course this is very powerful especially
if you turn on warnings as errors you're
gonna blow up in or when you compile
this so one of the things that you can
do is you can say well for this
particular case here let's get rid of
that so we get the warning I can't say
that I want no labels disabled and for
everything you know in that particular
context or this in this case inside the
method it's gonna disable that check for
the knowable reference times but we can
also do this on the method level right
we can do it on the class itself or we
can move this to the namespace we're
outside that which will do it for this
entire file so we don't have to go into
our project file and enable this for
everywhere we can simply go ahead and
disable it for the project and then go
ahead and enable this wherever we want
to start refactoring code and make it a
little bit better I think this is a
really great addition to the language
especially having done a lot of kasnia
Rieslings work recently where everything
is not a little by default you have to
opt in to things being null and the
compiler is gonna slap you really hard
on your fingers if you try to force it
to do something that you're not supposed
to so this is a great addition what
they've also added now is there's no
coalescing assignment which will allow
us to say if the person is null I want
you to do this thing here so instead of
us having to write person is equal to a
person person right
that's going to be a fuel character
slice and you know with the I'll show
you a feature that's coming in the
future which won't compile you know I
didn't have time to implement all the
features myself and we have the
documents can be able to do this
they'll be nasty but that requires a
runtime change its role and they haven't
done any runtime changes for a very long
time most of the things that we see our
compiler magic but since they're doing
runtime changes they can add more and
more interesting features to language so
that's not all reference types that's a
kind of cool addition to the language
question
so your question is how do we handle if
we're using third-party libraries and
that this can use the kind of a false
sense of security because it could tell
you that you don't have a problem when
you might have a problem well it's not
gonna be foolproof it's not gonna look
through how everything works inside
those libraries you have to trust the
library author to do this properly on
their end but you know you can still at
last I showed you like even if you have
a no object you can you can force this
to to be null right so if we say person
here is going to be equal to null even
though we we might not be allowed to do
that it's gonna give us a warning but
you know I can promise that this is not
going to be null and we'll still have a
actually I can promise it down here and
we can promise that this is not going to
be in home afterwards right so there we
go sorry so even though that the
compiler is trying to give us a little
bit of help of course it's not gonna
find all the the cases and we still have
to write our tests has their code and
we're still gonna end up having problems
but it's kind of a first guard for
finding the null reference exceptions so
you're right it can be a full sense of
security about it's it's still better
than we what we had earlier please I
reckon all right so that's the inaudible
reference types now let's talk about
using declarations and I actually added
a demo in here from so that I saw on
Twitter yesterday which is really
interesting but we'll get to that after
this first one so now with using
declarations or enhanced use things one
of the things that we can do is that we
can say I want to introduce the using
block that's disposed whenever the
method now ends right whenever this
method is completed it's kind of called
dispose on whatever we use using baran
so I don't have to wrap this entire
thing in a block looking like this here
because if we are we have multiple use
things inside the method it's gonna end
up being nasty and not looking at that
very nice so now we can say using var up
here at the top and this is now going to
make sure that we dispose this HTTP
client whenever the method is completed
so how do we abuse this other
programming languages like go for
instance has an interesting notion of DD
for keyword
which means that we can now defer
execution of something until the method
ends so this method here I'm simply
saying well I want to create a new thing
here which I'm going to defer to execute
whenever the method ends and this comes
from from this guy here
Ruben he works for Microsoft totally
smart guy and you know this is this is
interesting so what we're doing here is
that we are simply we have a struct here
that's implementing I disposable which
means that when this method here
disposes it's going to invoke the action
that I passed to the constructor which
means that this code here is going to be
executed when this method is done makes
sense so if I run this here it's gonna
say hello and DC and then from Phillip
right so we now deferred that execution
to the end of the method some other
programming languages like go has this
default in the language and this is an
interesting thing so let's see the using
declarations small additions like that
are very welcome into language alright
so another interesting thing is anyone
here we use local functions a few you Oh
a lot of you so you know if you're using
local functions one of the drawbacks is
that if you accidentally use a local
variable in your class or in the context
or a property in your class is going to
capture that entire context as a
reference to that object you can change
things and you know it becomes kind of
nasty so I have this over-engineering
method here inside my computed which is
now accessing my my name property inside
the class and that's not very nice right
because now it has to capture that into
this thing here and the generated code
for this gets rather ugly so what
they've introduced is a way for us to
have a static local function now what
that means is that I can no longer
access things inside the class or inside
this method itself which means that I
promised that the over-engineer method
in this case is not going to have any
implications whenever I call it so
you'll have to trust whatever you pass
into it and what its returning and
that's a nice addition especially if you
use local functions quite a bit
alright one of my favorite features
added to c-sharp 8 is going to be
something called asynchronous dreams
which means that we can now work with
streams of data in an asynchronous
manner which has been you've been able
to do this before but now this syntax
allows us to much more easily work with
these streams of data so imagine in this
case here I call this method which is
going to return me a collection of data
but each element is going to be coming
to me asynchronously so we're able to
handle each element as they arrive all
right it could be reading lines from the
disk it could be fetching things from
the web and you know reading chunks of
bytes by byte by byte right so the way
that we do this is by applying the awake
keyword inside of our foreach loop to
say that this here is going to
asynchronously loop over some data that
we get so if we check this
implementation what we have here is we
now have a way for us to say for each
element from 0 to 10 you know we're
gonna go ahead and fetch some data we're
gonna load something from this we're
gonna process some data and the key
thing here is that we're using yield
return together with the I a synchronous
I a sync enumerable this is going to do
all the magic forest it's going to set
up this state machines and all of that
all of those interesting things alright
so the yield return here we'll make sure
that it notifies whoever is calling this
method a synchronously that you can now
process this particular element so if we
run this application it'll stream out
the numbers to the console here it's not
blocking you know it's it's just
processing this as it goes on a little
bit of a more real-world scenario is if
we use the file system to load some data
and then we might process that now to
make it easier I've just added some some
delay to make sure that you know it
works so we have this method called get
lyrics it's going to use the new using
declarations as well to open a stream to
a file on my disk
it'll dispose of that whenever this
method is done right even though we are
synchronously returning elements as we
go on it'll make sure that it disposes
that properly at the end of the method
and then we're saying that we want to
read each line asynchronously
as long as that doesn't return any nulls
and then we want to do some processing
on that data
maybe chunk it up maybe it's a large set
of customer data or whatever you know
and then we want to return that line
back to the caller before I run this
there's gonna be another change in
c-sharp 9 probably where you can do this
in line as well so you wouldn't have
that line variable outside of that scope
as well but that's coming later on all
right so now if we run this it should
asynchronously retrieve or return the
data to our console right let's see if
you all know the song alright so you
were just rickrolled by the console app
so that's pretty cool so this here is
now leveraging this newest synchronous
reims with the async and avoid keywords
so even though that the async and a
weight and all the asynchronous
principles have been around for a long
time they're still adding improvements
to those language features and the way
that we integrate with api's and so
forth it's interesting because even
before they release this feature I tried
to do something similar like this I try
to use the yield return in anything for
his context that I wanted to use down
here for each loop and so forth but it
just didn't work so this was a really
nice addition all right so the the final
one that I really don't want to show you
because it's really nasty it's default
interface methods I'm not really
particularly found of being able to
introduce methods on my interfaces but
let's go through the problem they're
trying to solve so we have this
interface here called I cache I have my
memory cache or in-memory cache that
implements this particular interface it
allows me to in this case here just sets
up the dictionary allows me to add and
get and retrieve a elements based on a
particular key super simple it's just a
over-engineer solution for a dictionary
right which I'm using anyways but I
could be implementing this for readies
cache and whatnot now of course I can
use this in my application in a rather
simple matter I can say well how about
just add two elements I don't care about
the particular types of those those
things but now I'm the library author of
this interface and some default
implementation
and I want to improve this interface I
want to add generics right but if I were
to simply I don't want to add a generic
interface which I could do this but I
don't want to do that instead I want to
introduce I want to introduce two new
methods that allows us to leverage the
get and add methods in a generic manner
right
super simple I'm simply saying here this
is going to be a generic method it takes
the the the generic parameter here is
the key and that'll return turn a value
pretty simple although the problem now
is that I have to implement this if I
bring down this needed package all of
the people that are used my package will
now have to implement my new methods and
we might not want to do that because for
library authors and open-source
community workers you know they they get
a lot of hate for you know updating
their interfaces and and so forth people
get about upset about the most tiny
things so what I can do now is that I
can say well I want to provide a default
implementation for this so I can use the
the expression body remember to do that
or I can use a normal normal method body
for this as well so now all of a sudden
the the warning goes away on my class
here so I have no idea that I updated
this package and I have no clue that I
need to update this this particular
class because we were providing these
default implementations right it's an
interesting addition to the language and
you know if you look at this it kind of
introduces multiple inheritance as well
because I can implement multiple
interfaces if I have multiple interfaces
that implement their own methods things
are going to break and blow up so how do
we use these different methods now well
I've implemented that my in-memory cache
implements the interface that has these
default implementations but what's
interesting here is that if we look at
the methods available on my end memory
cache I don't have a generic version of
AD so that's at least pretty good so how
do we leverage these things here I
reckon that no one's gonna run into this
scenario where are you not going to be
able to see this because everyone's
injecting their interfaces right so if
we force this
be an eye cache and now we check which
methods we have available here we now
have the generic versions so as long as
I'm telling this here that I have the
interface it's going to allow us to use
the generic versions and it's just gonna
work and of course if I do this it's
gonna blow up because my whoops because
it's going to try and get hello world
and Stack Overflow for some reason great
or tells me to go read Stack Overflow I
don't know all right so that's I think
it's an interesting addition to the
language but I see the problems with
introducing this as well because it now
allows us to firstest do the multiple
inheritance thing but the good thing is
that you don't have access to two
particular instance of the object so
there one of the problems if you're
doing C++ there's many problems with
that but if you do C++ and you do
multiple inheritance you know you have
access to the instance of the object but
you don't have that here you can't
magically access this here so this will
not be available hopefully not all right
well you would battle to access the the
static things or the things on the
interface but you wouldn't be actually
actually able to access the the instance
itself right so that's all of the
interesting features that I'm gonna show
you in the C sharp 8 let's now talk a
little bit about the things I didn't
show you in C sharp 8 so we went through
a whole lot of interesting features
everything from you know default
interface methods to you noble reference
types the recursive pattern async
streams and hence usings and ranges and
localizing assignment and Static local
functions so what I think is interesting
is that they have the capability of
adding all of these amazing language
features still after after so many years
of this language being on the planet
right they still find a way to improve
it because you know building software in
in 2019 or 2020 it's not the same as
building software 20 years ago so the
language needs to evolve with the
community and with the people that use
the language for the particular types of
applications that we're building the
features that I didn't show you is read
only members but that's only for struct
so most of us probably don't use stock
structs on a daily basis but you can
ensure that a member in your struct is
read only which means that it doesn't
have any implications when you call it
or when you use it on any of the other
things on your particular struct we can
have alternative interpolated verbatim
strings and stack alakina stood contexts
as well as unmanaged eric starts right
now
what's coming after c-sharp 8 I'm not
sure what the version numbers gonna be
Microsoft tends to to skip a few numbers
especially when it comes to 9 so we'll
see if the next version is gonna be X or
10 or every one I call it one of the
things I like to say is that you saw the
the milestone for c-sharp aid had a lot
of features right 89% of the features
they added in the milestone didn't
getting to the language which means that
we shouldn't be sad if they cut the
features so whatever I show you here
some of the features have been on their
to-do list since c-sharp 6 and I bet
that a lot of these language features
that I recently added have been on their
to-do list even long before that you
know the reason for them rewriting the
compilers is because it's really hard to
add things to a very old code base we
all know that just thrown code out and
rewriting it is the best approach so one
thing that I showed you earlier is this
target type new expression so instead of
having to specify the thing we're
creating we're now moving the thing that
we're creating over to this side we're
not really saving a lot of characters
maybe three or four if we serve our
keyword but where it becomes interesting
is that in this case here I'm creating
this dictionary of string and list
integers and I can simply say give me a
new instance of this and in my
collection initializer I can say give me
a new instance off you know whatever
that thing is and it'll just figure that
out
and this here requires a runtime change
so they're probably gonna wait until a
little I don't know dotnet 5 which is
going to be the the next version of.net
where they moving everyone over to core
ok so one more thing I want to do is
allow us to again write less characters
so instead of having to be very explicit
about in this case here I'm creating
this is tuple here with 2d file
values is going to give us a default of
integer and default of string why not
just allow us to say give me the default
of this tuple and it just figures that
out simple compiler magic not really a
major feature traged language so one of
the things I really enjoy and I hope
this is going to get here soon because
what's interesting as well with the way
they work with the compiler is that you
know c-sharp 8 was released together
with document core 3.0 which was
released what six months after Visual
Studio 2019 so if you update Visual
Studio today you will get the latest
version of the language and dotnet core
right and the same thing goes for four
new features like this here the generic
attributes if they just add that to the
compiler they could ship that with the
next version of Visual Studio this means
it can become very confusing if you were
in large organizations where people tend
to have different versions of Visual
Studio so how many of you have wanted to
do generic attributes if you've done
filters in asp.net and you know it's
kind of a few of you I've wanted to do
that so now they're introducing the the
way for us to do that previously you had
to inject you know the type in your
constructor and you know that became a
little bit ugly but no longer have to do
that we can now simply say we have this
generic attribute don't know why it's
taken them so long but apparently
there's maybe some some some hard things
to solve when it comes to the attributes
another nice addition to the language is
the color expression attributes which is
a way for us to apply an attribute on
one of these parameters to our method to
say well I want you to take the the
argument or the the expression that was
passed in the condition here and inject
that automatically as a string here so
all that's doing is allowing us to skip
writing the message ourselves for debug
assert here and the compiler will
generate this code for us so if we have
a you know a logger or we have a test we
can now get a little bit more better
information out of this here so library
authors will be able to leverage this
and make it a little bit easier okay so
we also want ways for us to check if
types are equal to two null or they're
not nola or if there are particular
things so of course I want to say for
all I could use pattern matching to
solve the same thing
but why not allow us to introduce
something called negated condition of
statements so we can translate this
thing here into maybe shape is not a
triangle or if not shape is a triangle
or unless shape is a triangle I don't
think they've really decided on which
way to go here I'm not fond of adding
new new keywords for a thing like this
here alright but you know maybe it's not
it's a great addition to language and of
course improving the ways that we work
with nulls no conditional awaits if you
were doing a lot of asynchronous work
you might have seen this before where
you check if the task is not equal to no
simply await the task otherwise just
return all we can now say await the task
if it's not null this here expect out to
be a little bit harder for them to
implement because it's involved in the
state machine and all of that
since the sharp six they wanted to
introduce something called record types
record types is a way for us to
introduce a DTO or a model if you so
like so in this case here I have my
triangle of shape it has all of these
we're very standard things right and a
lot of us do this all the time we create
D tos for for all the things in our
domain and it kind of gets tedious as
well if you want to be able to introduce
equality checks for the properties and
so forth so why not just allow us to say
I want a record of a triangle where I
require a side of a B and C and then
this inherits from my particular type of
shape here when I compile this here the
idea is that it generates a whole bunch
of different things of course we get a
constructor that shows us that this
requires us to specify a B and C when we
instantiate this here it would introduce
an equality check that if you compare
two triangles it will in fact compare
the properties of that triangle and not
compare the instance that's pretty cool
and then of course we want everything to
be immutable which means that you
shouldn't be able to change the triangle
once you've created it in order for you
to create a new triangle or change the
triangle you need to create a new one
and that's why we here at the end we
have this thing here it's creating a new
triangle based on what we're passing
into this width width method here it's a
nice pattern then of course getting a
deconstruct out of this by default
we can use pattern matching and use the
tuple expressions and so forth so I
think this is one of the the better
additions to to the language and
hopefully this is going to come soon but
they promised this in c-sharp six I
think they had a version of this in
c-sharp six and it was just scratched
the tough thing to do here is to solve
this for inheritance personally I think
that they should just scratch the
capability of doing inheritance that's
an easy way to fix it
but maybe that's just the consulting
consultant in me talking alright so I
showed you this as well the declaration
expressions so why have having to write
our character declared that at the line
above here when we're only using that
inside our while loop here that means
that we could use the character after
the while loop becomes nasty why not
just allow us to do that in line with
the while loop and only have it
available in that particular context so
you can see a pattern with the feature
state they add to the language it's
about avoiding null ability or avoiding
us to do null reference exceptions it's
allowing us to write more code that's
easier for us to understand and in this
case it's going to be a little bit less
error-prone right because we move that
thing into that particular context and
you know no one can can use that outside
of this method so if you're a lot of
developers working on the same project
all these small features make up for
some really nice addition to the
language in it's kind of tedious for us
to instantiate dictionaries so why not
introduce a syntax that allows us to to
make it a little bit better and you see
here at the bottom of the slides I can
share the slides that are on but I have
references to the seizure of language
repository where they talk about all of
these different things so this here is
going to introduce a new syntax that
allows us to instantiate one of these
dictionaries a little bit nicer and just
figures out the types and so forth now
finally or one more feature that I want
to talk about is extension everything so
one of the problems with extension
methods in c-sharp is that we can can't
really extend things like the integers
or doubles or you know the things that
we don't really own that way so in this
case here imagine that I have this
interface that allows us to simply add
this bar property on something so
whoever is implementing this interface
will get the
the board property how about allowing me
to add this to an integer wouldn't that
be pretty cool I don't know why you
would but you can do it with extensions
everything you can say well I want to
create an extension for integer all
right so I'm saying create an extension
for for integer that I call in few here
it's going to implement my particular
interface and then inside the context of
my application I can create a new
integer and I can think call X dot bar
here and that will just work there are
some really nice applications to this
here but it's also very dangerous
because all of a sudden you end up
having some really interesting
extensions in your applications and
potential problems as well but if you do
a lot of math it's nice to be able to
extend in sand and doubles and decimals
and all of that and floats you know so I
think it's a good addition for for some
use cases but not for all of them it's
the same with the extension methods
right they have their place in the
applications but I've seen a lot of
developers abusing that as well so you
know use all the language features with
caution and you know think twice before
you just apply things in the apps and
you'll be fine so it's interesting
because that's not all of the features
that they're going to add but that's the
ones that I'm smart enough to explain at
least we're also getting at something
called type classes which I'm certainly
not smart enough to explain I've read
the the proposal for that language
feature probably ten times and I still
don't get it
so hopefully we're never gonna get the
feature because that'll make a hard time
for me to make a talk about it so and
they were also known as the lambo
discard parameter parameter null
checking relax ordering of partial on
ref modifiers native ends permits of
span of int attributes on the local
functions function pointers and an and
all those assignment operators so
there's a bunch of features they want to
add to the language and I've pretty much
gone through all the the champions and
the things that they they might add to
the language and our that's on their
to-do list but you know we never know
which features are going to get into the
language itself but hopefully some of
the ones that I've talked about here in
the C sharp next part is going to make
it into language so now if we look at
all the things that are happening in
c-sharp from seizure of eight to c-sharp
whatever the next verse is going to be
there's a whole bunch of interesting
features coming
to the language and I'm a highlighted a
few of them that I I like and not like I
don't know why I highlighted the default
interface methods because I really don't
like that oh well you can see her
there's so many things coming to the
language you know they're not done yet
so the language is evolving with all of
us that are building software they're
adding things that make it easier for us
to to work with the language they're
making it easier for people that are
working in other types of paradigms to
make the transition over to c-sharp if
you work with f-sharp you can pretty
much write c-sharp like you would write
F sharp or if you're coming from a Java
world you can probably do a little of
c-sharp as well so you know there's a
lot of things that here that make it
easier for us to to build software and I
think it's a good addition to the
language so you know looking through
whatever we got in c-sharp one through
seven people might have thought that
this language is now done there's not
much more things to add to the language
but I reckon there's still a lot more to
add to it and if we look at the heaps of
things they're doing improvements for in
c-sharp ada onwards there's a whole
bunch of things in here and they're
probably not going to stop there and
what's interesting as well with the
languages in the compilers being open
source is that the languages doesn't
have they don't have to be you know have
feature parity anymore so VB and c-sharp
no longer have to have the exact same
features which means that if there's a
lot of c-sharp language designers
working on c-sharp they might ship the
feature for C sharp faster than for for
VB so now the there's a lot of things
happening in the c-sharp world and it's
a great time to be a c-sharp developer
and I think all these additions are
awesome alright so that's it for for my
talk I'm Philipp Ekberg it's been a
pleasure talking to you on your way out
please leave a green thing in the box if
you don't do that tell me why so I can
improve for next time and if you have
any questions you can come up afterwards
or just throw something in my face when
you see me in the hallway thank you so
much